Okay. Are you ready for the answer, here it goes. So, you have 1, 2, 3, 4
lines, and I didn't pick up my pen. This task is important because it
demonstrates a very important principle of creative thinking. You have to break
out of your mental perceptual limits, these limits you might not even realize
you have. We were going to discuss a little bit more when we talk about problem
solving. But here, if you struggled with this, you probably didn't realize you
impose a square on the nine dots, like this. A lot of people who struggle with
this try to stay within the box. This is a very literal example of thinking
outside of the box. If you think about things differently, from a different
perspective, you may come up with a creative solution. Breaking outside of your
self-imposed mental limits. Highly creative people do this intuitively,
automatically. For more problems like this and to demonstrate how creative
thinking can be assessed, go to the website we put in the instructor's
comments.